الساده سيتحول الى قنبله مائيه قد تفقد
مصر والسودان الخيار العسكري وهذا لنلقي
نظره اقرب الى الخريطه لنفهم لماذا كميه
المياه خلف السد منذ انتهاء الملا الثاني
اي قبل عام ونصف العام من الان تهدد بجرف
مدن مصريه وسودانيه الى البحر المتوسط ان
حدث طوفان السد يواجه بالاساس خطر
الانهيار بنسبه 50 في المئه والاسباب عده
اولا طبيعه المنطقه التي تحتوي على فوالق
ارضيه ليست مناسبه بالطبع لبناء السدود
موقعه في منطقه جبليه في بني شنغول
واحتماليه انحدار صخور قابله للتفتيت مع
الطبيعه المطريه المسببه للسيول ونذكر
مشاهدينا خطر الانهيار بدا منذ ان وضعت
اديس ابابا حجر الاساس لهذا السد سد
النهضه في 2011 وذلك بسبب معامل الامان
المن خفض في السد والذي اثار قلق واشنطن
والبنك الدولي منذ ذلك الحين واكدت اللجنه
الدوليه اثناء معاينه السد في 2011 ان
وضعه مرعب ومخيف فماذا عن وضعه الان
[موسيقى]